[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه مشجع
كره القدم في كافه انحاء العالم وتحديدا
في فرنسا والارجنتين يحسبون الدقائق
المتبقي على مباراه نهائي كاس العالم في
قطر والتي ستبقى محفوره في الذاكره ساعه
واحده فقط تفصلنا عن مبارزه بين بلدين
لصناعه التاريخ الفرنسيون يطمحون الى ان
يكونوا ثالث منتخب يفوز بكاس العالم ثلاث
مرات في تاريخ المونديال اما بالنسبه
للارجنتين فان امالهم واحلامهم تنعقد على
ليونيل ميسي الذي يراه كثيرون اعظم لاعب
في تاريخ كره القدم على الاطلاق مشاهدينا
نبدا بالعناوين
قمه الارجنتينيه فرنسيه بعد قليل على
نهائي كاس العالم
الامن الايرانيه يمنع المحتاجين المصابين
من العلاج ومئات الكتاب والباحثين يطالبون
بوقف فوري للاعدامات
الدخان والبارود والخطر
المعارك بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
[تصفيق]
ازمه الاضراباتي تتفاقم ببريطانيا الحكومه
تجذب 1200 جندي مكان العمال المطربين
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من المباراه
المرتقبه لنهائي كاس العالم بين منتخب اي
الارجنتين وفرنسا حامل اللقب حيث يتواصل
كما نشاهد في هذه اللقطات التي ننقلها لكم
مباشره الان نشاهد توافد المشجعين الى
ملعب لوسيلا في الدوحه من المرتقب ايضا
حضور شخصيات كبيره لهذا الحدث من فنانين
وسياسين وايضا رياضيا
وهذه صور مباشره تحديدا من الارجنتين في
عمليه لترجيع طبعا منتخبهم الذي يلعب في
نهائي كاس العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وقبل المباراه النهائيه التي ينتظر
الملايين متابعتها بعد قليل اعلن الرئيس
الارجنتيني البرتو فرنانديز اعلن انه
سيشاهد النهائي المرتقب في بلده كتب على
تويتر مثل الملايين من ابناء بلادي
ساستمتع بنهائي كاس العالم في الوطن اما
الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون فقرر حضور
المباراه النهائيه في الملعب حيث يزور
الدوحه وذلك للمره الثانيه في غضون ثلاثه
ايام بعد ما حضر مباراه نصف النهائي امام
المغرب
اذا وصلت ترقب العالم نتيجه المباراه
النهائيه لكاس العالم التي تقام كما ذكرنا
على ارض استاد لو سيلف العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه تشهد كافه المدن السعوديه ايضا
استعدادات كبيره من ابرزها تجهيز عشرات
المواقع بشاشات عملاقه لمشاهده المباراه
التي ستجمع منتخبي الارجنتين وفرنسا
العربيه ستطلع على التوقعات الشارع
السعودي قبل انطلاق نهائي بطوله كاس
العالم قطر 20 22 الليله بين فرنسا
والارجنتين دعونا نتابعه
بس ان شاء الله
اعرب اعتقد انه ان شاء الله مسيحي كله دور
في مباراه اليوم ان شاء الله نتمنى ولو
فرنسا مستوى ممتاز يعني جيد
للثلاثه واحد باذن الله فرنسا اليوم يعني
مستواها افضل اتوقع اثنين واحد والله
اتوقع 3-0 الى ثنتين ميسي
كام امنيه اتمنى الارجنتين تفوز
وكاتوقع برده اتوقع ان شاء الله الارجنتين
تفوز بواحد صفر او اثنين واحد
وينضم الينا من الدوحه ليس بزاري موفد
العربيه الى هناك ليس اهلا بك انقل لنا
الاجواء من عندك
وليس استوديو تعش بالناس هي سيلون من
البشر الكثير منهم يحتفلون بالعيد الوطني
القطري والكثير منهم ياتون
لوسيل الذي نشاهد بالصوره وتوقفت يعني
استوقفت قبل ثوان من الان هذه السيده
اسبانيول
نصف اسبانيا ونصف ارجنتينيه واتت مع
اطفالها لمشاهده المباراه من اخيرا خنتي
[موسيقى]
اكيد المنتخب الارجنتيني
هسه
هي تعيش في قطر
مع اطفالها وسالتها عن زوجها قالت لي هو
سبقنا الى الملعب الكثير
المشجعين المنتخب الارجنتيني
لون بشكل يعني على علمتني حافلات وبكميات
مختلفه عن بعض منهم وصل في ساعات بعد
الظهر الباكر قبل غروب الشمس بقليل وقاموا
بالدخول مباشره لقرع الطبول داخل استاد او
ملعب لوسيل هنا وهي طبعا فضلت ان تاتي
مؤخرا مع اطفالها كما نشاهد في
الصورها نيكولا وليو ليو ميسي
[موسيقى]
ما اسم اللاعب الارجنتيني الشهير ليونيل
ميسي
بس اتاكد من الترجمه
خمسه تتوقع النتيجه
[موسيقى]
بينما الصور نقولها فيها نوع كما ذكرت
سائل من توافد الناس خبرنا واين يتركزون
يعني داخل الملعب وبالخارج ايضا اليس كذلك
نعم نعم بدي اشرح لك الصوره بالتفصيل
ميسون نحن وصلنا قبل قليل الى مواقف
السيارات وعندما قمنا بالمباشر قبل قليل
فلاشه الرابعه كنا نقطع السيول بهذه
السيول هذه البشر في منطقه الوسيله ونحن
الان باتجاه الملعب هناك وفي الطريق هناك
مباشر فعلينا ان نقوم بهذا المباشر ونتكلم
مع الذين يذهبون الى منطقه الملعب لنكمل
المباشر او المداخلات المباشره من هناك
الحسود يعني هذا الملعب الليله سوف يتسع
لتسعين الف شخص
بالتساويين بالتساوي
[موسيقى]
80% بتوقع همم
المنتخب الارجنتيني و30% او 20% من
المنتخب الفرنسي على كل حال من سوريا واحد
ازرق فاتح وواحد ازرق
مباشره الان اذا ننظر بالصوره الاحتفالات
كما نشاهد الان في ستاد لوسيل تقام
الالعاب الناريه احتفالا او تمهيدا
للمباراه التي ستختم هذا هذا المونديال
بين فرنسا والارجنتين على كل حال الرئيس
الفرنسي ماكغو ياتي مره اخرى
وهناك الكثير من المشجعين الذين اتوا من
مناطق مختلفه ليس فقط الارجنتين بل من
بلدان عربيه وبلدان اجنبيه اخرى لمشجع
المنتخب الارجنتيني وميسي وعلى سيره
الرئيس ذكرت انه 20% فقط من المشجعين
الفرنسيين ولكن رئيس الدوله نفسه متواجد
قد ايه بيقولوا ليس بانه مثل هذا التواجد
له تاثير على معنويات اللاعبين
هذا مهم جدا ورسدناه اصلا ميسون بمباريات
المغرب كان عدا ان الرئيس المشجعون بحد
ذاتهم هم جزء من اللعبه رجراجي ما ننسى
لما قال هو اللاعب رقم 12 المشجع هو
اللاعب رقم 12 في المباراه وهذا مهم جدا
لرفع معنويات وطمائنه اللاعبين الفرنسيين
داخل هذا استديوم بان الرئيس معهم وانه
بانه جزء من اللعبه يعني اذا دخلنا اذا
نتذكر اذا حكينا عن سوق واقف عندما تمشي
في سوق واقف قبل ايام عندما حضر المباراه
التي لعبت فيها فرنسا كان الكثير من الذين
يحتفون ام من مشجعين المنتخب الفرنسي وليس
اللاعبين
تحيا فرنسا وهذا جزء مهم همم للاعبين
والمدربهم
وجميع الفرنسيين الذين يشاهدون هذه
المباراه في فرنسا هناك شمالا على شاشات
التلفازهم ويشجعون المنتخب الفرنسي ما
ننسى ان اليوم اليوم احد والطاس بارد في
فرنسا وهذا كثير يساعد على مشاهده تلك
المباراه التي ستقام بعد اقل من ساعه
بتوقع او ساعه ونصف الساعه مش حامل الساعه
هلا بايدي بس متوقع
دقيقه
الكل عن بعد الدقائق والسرعه
من الدوحه
الى ملف الاحتجاجات في ايران فقط
انهاء سريع لم وصفوه بالعمليات المشئومه
اكد المواقعون على البيان ان النظام الذي
لا يستمع لاصوات المتظاهرين نظام يخفي
افتقاره للشرعيه باللجوء الى التهديد
والاعدام وسيرها قريبا جدا دعائم قوته
تنهار اشار البيان ان الاعدامات اثرت موجه
من الغضب بين الناس لكن النظام تجاهل ردود
الفعل بهدف ارسال الدعم الى القوى القمعيه
جاء في البيان ايضا بان النظام اقدر حتى
الان احكاما بالاعدام على الاثنين و20
متظاهرا ويواجه المزيد منهم اتهامات
بالحرابه والافساد في الارض
هذا وتجمع عدد من رجال الاطفاء امام مبنى
مجلس بلديه مدينه تبريز عاصمه محافظه
اذربيجان احتجاجا على الاوضاع المعيشيه
المزريه التي تشهدها البلاد
يلا الحمد لله تاتي هذه التحركات في وقت
لقيت فيه طبيبه ايرانيه تدعى ايضا رستومي
لقيت حذفها في ظروف غامضه في محافظه
غلستان هذا هو اكدت الطواقيم الطبيه في
ايران المشاركه في اضراب يبدا غدا الاثنين
احتجاجا على مقتل الطبيبه نفى مصدر لايران
انترناشونال سيناريو انتحار ايضا رستمين
التي كانت تعالج جرح الانتفاضه الشعبيه
مشيرا الى ان الادله المتوفره تؤكد ان
النظام الايراني هو من قام بقتلها بعد
اعتقالها تم دفن جثمان الطبيب يوم الجمعه
في ما كانت بعض التقارير تشكك في صحه
سيناريو الوفاه المشبوهه في مستشفى جمران
بالعاصمه طهران
قناه ايران انترناشونال ذكرت ايضا ان
عناصر الامن الايراني منعه ايضا الفتاه
المعتقله الهام مدرسي من عرضها على طبيب
رغم تدهور حالتها الصحيه اعرضت عائلته
مدرسيه البالغه من العمر 32 عاما عن القلق
حيال حرمان الهام من الرعايه الطبيه وعدم
القدره على الوصول الى ملفها الطبيه
ينضم الينا على كلن من اصل عضو منظمه حقوق
الانسان الاحوازيه عمار كسائي اهلا بك
استاذ عمار اسمح لي انا ابدا ببيان
المثقفين الذي صدر قراءه في هذا البيان
وهل الرساله فقط متعلقه بالاعدامات هذا ما
حركهم ام ماذا
تحيه لك وللمشاهد الكرام لا بطبيعه حال
المثقفين منذ زمن المثقفين وفي الحقيقه
كافه
فئات الشعب الايراني هم يريدون حلول جذريه
لما يجري في الداخل واعتقد ان هذا البيان
لن يكون اول بيان ولا اخر بيان لانه هناك
الكثير من الكتاب المثقفين الاطباء
الممثلين كافه شرائح المجتمع الايراني
عبروا عن استيائهم ورفضهم لما يجري خاصه
الاعدامات خاصه
الذي يتعرض له المحتجون كما ان الوضع
المزري والمتدهور هو همم دفعها هؤلاء
لكتابه هذه البيان للنشر هذا البيان
لايجاد حلول للمشاكل الموجوده حاليا
الوضع الاقتصادي المعيشي لانه بحسب ما
فهمنا رجالات الاطفاء سيضربون بسبب
الاوضاع المعيشيه هل رقعه الاحتجاجات
موزعه ما بين من هو يطالب بحقوق المراه
وااا بين هؤلاء الذين يرفعون شعارات
معيشيه
في الحقيقه هي الاحتجاجات في الاونه
الاخيره تنوعت يعني شملت مثل رجال الاطفال
قطاع النفط في الاحراج اا قطاع الصحه
الكثير من القطاعات وايضا يعني لما ننظر
الى
يقدر من 40,000 تومان سعر الدولار الواحد
اي 400,000 همم ريال مقابل العمله
الايرانيه وايضا هناك من دعوا الى سحب
ارصدتهم واموالهم الموجوده في البنوك بغيت
الضغط على النظام وتقليل السيوله الموجوده
همم
كل يعمل حسب ما همم يراه مناسب لكي يجعل
النظام يرضى ويتراجع امام مطالب المحتاجين
وايجاد حلول جاذبيه لا يكتفي بالقمل كحل
وحيد كلنا ذكرت بانه يفعل ما يراه مناسبا
للضغط على النظام بمعنى اخر حتى الان همم
ما حدث على الارض وكل هذه الفتره ليس هناك
من يدير هذه التظاهرات
التظاهرات ليست لديها قياده موحده مثلا
سياسيه معروفه ولكن في الداخل يوجد تنسيق
بين المتظاهرين وخاصه اعتقد براي حسب
متابعاته ان المتظاهرين ينسقون انفسهم عبر
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي خاصه مثلا حملات
تويتر وحملات الموجوده في الانستغرام
وارقم حاجب هذه
التطبيقات ولكن المتظاهرين يجون سبيل
لفتحها عبر الفي بي ان وتقنيات اخرى
ما بينهم كما ان اصحاب المهن واصحاب
الشخصيات او النقابات ايضا هما يلصقون
فيما بينهم ونستطيع نقول انها تلقائيا من
المجتمع وليس لها همم
مرحله من المراحل ان تكون لديها قيادات
سياسيه تقودها
اعتقد بطبيعه الحال الان نحن امام ثوره
الثوره بمعنى لا تتطلب ان تقول لها قياده
سياسيه لانه الان الوضع اختلف وليس كما
مثلا في ثوره 79 الان ال الشعوب هي تدير
نفسها
جميع الشخصيات وجميع
ان هم ضمن المحتجين وضمن المتظاهرين
ولديه تليفون لديه اتصال بالعالم لديه
انترنت لديه انشاء نظر فاعتقد اليوم
الجميع
المحتاجين جميع المتظاهرين جميع الجماهير
هم قادم بمعنى اي هم يقررون ويريدون قيام
نظام همم ديمقراطيراقي
الاحوازيه عمار كسائي شكرا جزيلا لك
من ايران الى العراق افاد مصدر امني بسقوط
10 ضحايا من الشرطه الاتحاديه من بينهم
ضابط برتبه رائد اثرا في شارع عبوه ناسفه
استهدفت عجلتين للقوات الامنيه في محافظه
كركوك شماليه بغداد
الى لبنان الان دانا البطريرك الماروني
بشاره الراعي مواصفات جريمه اغتيال الجندي
الايرلندي الذي قتل في بلده العقربيه جنوب
لبنان مساء الاربعاء الماضي
هذه الحادثه الماساويه
التي تشبه وجه لبنان وسمعته
عندما تستوجب وتحقيقا شفافا
لبنانيه وامنيا
يكشف الحقيقه
ويجري العداله
لقد حان الوقت
بل حان من زمان
لان تضع الدوله يدها على كل سلاح متفلت
وغير شرعي
وتطبيق القرار 1701
لان التطبيقه حتى الان
كان انتقائيا وارتباطيا
ومقيدا بقرار قوى الامر الواقع
عوده نظام التدفئه الى العاصمه الاوكرانيه
بعد انقطاعا بسبب ضربات الروسيه
دور جديد يلعب القطاع السياحه في الاقتصاد
السعودي باستناف توفير مليون وظيفه جديده
وتسجيل 100 مليون زياره سنويا في 2030
بحسب رؤيه المملكه اليوم وبعد تسجيل 62
مليون زياره للمملكه في 2021 والمساهمه
اكثر من 5% من الاقتصاد السعودي فكيف يمكن
للسياحه ان تساهم بعشره في المياه وكيف
تصبح سعوديه وجهه عالميه السياحه السعوديه
ضمن الاسواق العربيه
تحت غيوم الجنوب ووسط جبالها والله على
صحن جرير اجمعنا في احباب وما تدري تمدح
اللمه ولا المشبوس مع نسمه هوا على بحر
الشرقيه
وبهارات ثري دي يا بعد حيي ماخذه من ريح
الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي طعم المميز
حاضر معنا فيكي الجمعاتنا الحلوه
28 حرفا
حطت بها رسائل للعالم
خطبته شعرا فكانت المعلقات
حاورت خياله فكانت الروايه
ترجمه اسرارا فبزغ نور المعرفه
بالعربي رساله للعالم
الرع
ايه
[موسيقى]
بنيناها معكم يوم بعد يوم
بنيناها بالتربيه الصح
في مزارع بالمعايير الاصح
لجاج اليوم
مع فيتامين سي وزنك وفيتامين دال يساعد
على تعزيز مناعتك يوم بعد يوم خلي سندروم
جزء من روتينك اليومي
[موسيقى]
يد الام ياما شافت طول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسه تعرف كيف تختار
حليب المراعي الطازج الفرق بايدين الامهات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا اظهرت مقاطع مصوره عبر
الجو وحجم الدمار الذي يلاحق بمدينه
مدمره بينما تشتعل الحرائق مع استمرار
الضربات الجويه الروسيه التي تستهدف خصيصا
البنا التحتيه للطاقه والتسليه حسب ما
تقول وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الكاميرا العربيه دخلت الى خطوط المواجهه
في جبهه باخموت وكبت معارك
المعارك من فنادق الجيش الاوكراني ومراسل
العربيه العربيه عذرا حذيفه لنا هذا
التقرير
لكن الوضع يختلف كليا هذه المره ويمكنك ان
تسمع القصف الذي يعلو صوته كل ما اقتربت
من مناطق القتال قصف بجميع انواع الاسلحه
المتوفره للطرفين اما الدخول فقد كان صعبا
نسبه لعوره الطرق وسوء الاحوال الجويه
[موسيقى]
هنا يجري قتال شرس العدو يهاجم بشكل مستمر
ونحن نعمل على ايقافه ما كان عليهم ان
يبداوا هذه الحرب
الارواح ولكن بالعوده الى سؤالك هناك قتله
والاعداد تتفاوت من منطقه الى اخرى لكني
لا استطيع ان اخبرك باعداد القتلى بخصوص
السلاح نحتاج الى مزيد من الاسلحه ونتمنى
ان تكون متطوره وبشكل عام نحن في اهبه
الاستعداد ونضرب جنودنا على مستوى عالي
حتى لا نسمح للعدو باحت اراضينا هذه تغطيه
حصريه لقناتي العربيه هو الحدث من خنادق
الجيش الاوكراني المطله مباشره على منطقه
تواجد القوات الروسيه هذه تسمى الجبهه صفر
الى هذا المكان ستكون امنا العدو على خط
التماس وانت هنا ستكون في امان في الداخل
وتحتمي من قصف المدفعيه والرصاص العربيه
والحدث حصريا في خنادق الجيش الاوكراني في
مواقع الجيش الاوكراني في جبهه الاخوه
الجبهه الاعنف والاشرس
تشاهدون اطلاق النار بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه لا يتوقف هذه
الجبهه هي الاكثر اشتعالا في الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني يمكنك السماع ايضا اطلاق
النار من جهه القوات الروسيه وكما تشاهدون
الجيش الاوكراني ايضا يقوم بالرد على
اطلاق النار من الجهاز الاخرى نحن الان
نشاهد بث مباشر عن طريق الكاميرا التي تم
وضعها هنا في هذه المنطقه طبعا هذه
المنطقه تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه وخنادق
الجيش الاوكراني القوات الروسيه تبعد في
هذا الاتجاه حوالي 500 متر فقط من هذا
المكان الذي نحن فيه عن طريق هذه الكاميرا
عن طريق البث المباشر الان يستطيع الجنود
هنا ان يراقبوا تحركات القوات الروسيه
الان نحن نشاهد بث مباشر لمواقع تمركز
الجيش الروسي في هذا الاتجاه حوالي 500
متر وابعد نقطه قد تكون حوالي 800 من هذا
الاتجاه
الفيديو
من داخل الخندق حركه القوات الروسيه من
خلف التل ومناطق تمركز الاليات والمعدات
الروسيه نحن نرى الان المنطقه التي
يتمركزون فيها اذا راعينا حركتهم في هذا
الاتجاه فهذه علامه هجوم نحونا هذا هو
الخندق الاخير في مناطق تمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه في جبهه باخموت في اتجاه هور
لفقه القوات الروسيه تبعد من هنا حوالي
500 متر فقط تتحرك جبهه القتال في جبهه
باخوت وهي جبهه عريضه في دونيسك في هذا
الاتجاه او ذاك حسب قدره اي من القوتين
الروسيه والاكرانيه على اجبار الاخرى على
الانسحابي او التخلي عن موقعها هذه
الخنادق التي نحن فيها الان وهي مناطق
تمركز الجيش الاخراني انت ساعتها وقامت
بحفرها وكانت تتركز فيها القوات الروسيه
الى القوات الاوكرانيه في عمليه هجوم مضاد
استطاعت ان تسيطر عليها لتصبح مواقع
اوكرانيه لقناتي العربيه والحدث الذي
فعادل ضخمود هورليكا من خلال هذه الجيشي
الاوكراني
هذا وقد قتل شخص وجرح خمسه اخرون لاحد في
ضربات اوكرانيه على منطقه بلغراد الروسيه
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا استهدفت الضربات
بالرود كبرى مدن المنطقه ما ادى الى اصابه
اربعه اشخاص كما طالت حيا قريبا حيث قتل
شخص وهو جرح اخر حسب ما قال حاكم بالجرود
مضيفا ان اضرارا لاحقات باربعه 10 منزلا
ونوافذ عده كما تحطمت
هذا وا قد قال رئيس بلديه كيف تالي كليتش
كو ان نظام التدفئه عداوه بالكامل الى
العاصمه الاوكرانيه بعد القصف الروسي
الاخير الذي استهدف البنا التحتيه ان كان
للمياه او للكهرباء وقالت كليتش كو على
تطبيق تلجرام قال انك كيف استعاده جميع
الخدمات بعد القصف الاخير وان جميع مصادر
امدادات التدفئه تعمل وبشكل طبيعيه هذا
وقال مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان روسيا اطلقت
اكثر من 70 صاروخا يوم الجمعه في واحده من
اعنف موجات قصفها منذ بدايه الحرب القصف
ادى الى انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في جميع
انحاء البلاد وتوقف نظام التدفئه وشبكه
المياه
عادت الى ما يقرب من سته ملايين شخص في
البلاد
وفي حرب اوكرانيا باتت الكواليس تحمل
خفايا ربما تغير مجريات الحرب او تجعلها
تخرج عن حدودها تقرير لصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه كشف ان واشنطن حاولت منع
مخطط اوكراني لاغتيال رئيس الاركان الروسي
اضافه الى حقائق ايضا مؤشرات وضحوا السبب
الاخفاقات الروسيه في ساحه المعارك
المتابعه
هكذا قالوا ويبدو انهم صادقون
فكواليس حرب اوكرانيا باتت خير دليل على
الامانع ان يخفي حليف حرب معلومات لتفادي
حرب اكبر تتخطى حدود روسيا واوكرانيا
تقرير لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز كشف سلسله من
الخفايا التي تدور في اروقه الحرب وربما
كانت سببا رئيسيا لما وصلت اليه حاله
القوات الروسيه
على راس خفايا الحرب واشنطن وبحسب تقرير
صحيفه الامريكيه حاولت منعا مخطط اوكراني
لاغتيال رئيس الاركان الروسي فاليري جراسي
موف عبر حجمها معلومات عن الاوكرانيين تخص
زيارته للخطوط الاماميه للحرب
اخفاقات تكتيكيه ولوجسيه ايضا عانى منها
الجيش الروسي اذ وصف جنود تم الوصول اليهم
عبر الهاتف داخل المستشفيات الروسيه انه
تم ارسالهم الى الحرب بقليل من الطعام
والتدريب والرصاص وبمعدادات لا يعرفون
كيفيه استخدامها
اما الهواتف المحموله التي استخدمها
الجنود الروس للاتصال بدويهم فكانت سيفا
ذا حدين اذ مكن ذلك الجيش الاوكراني من
تحديد مواقعهم واستهدافهم ايضا ساهمت بعض
الانقسامات داخل القوات الروسيه بخلافات
وصلت الى حد استهداف قائد دبابه نقطه
تفتيش روسيا بشكل متعمد وفقا نيويورك
تايمز
تقرير قدم قران جديده للحرب الدائره منذ
شهور فمن خطط المعارك الروسيه السريه
والاعتراضات والمقابلات مع الجنود الروس
وصولا الى جهود الولايات المتحده لمنع حرب
مباشره مع روسيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المزيد
يبكيني وابدا بتقرير نيويورك
نعم تحياتي لك والاساده المشاهدين الملفت
من هذا التقرير الذي نشرته نيورتايمز اييي
ان هناك التركيز ربما على جانب اخلاقيه
بين القوسين طبعا من قبل الولايات المتحده
التي تصور نفسها هو كانها بالفعل منعت
الجيش الاوكراني من استعداف رئيس هيئه
الاركان العامه للقوات الروسيه
سيدرا ولكن
التاكد من الصحه صعب بالاضافه الى الكون
الجانب الروسي لم يعلق على ذلك
فانه يمكن ان نقول ان
الانبار ربما تنسجن تماما في عداد الانباء
الاخرى الزائفه التي سبت يعني سيفها
بالماضي مرات عديده وشو تاثيرها اذا ما
كانت فعلا ليست حقيقيه هل لها ان تريح
تكون رسائل
اا تريح روسيا بطريقه او باخرى باعتبار
انه الولايات المتحده غير معنيه ب همم حرب
مباشره ومواجهه مباشره مع روسيا او لا
ربما تعني احراج لروسيا في ما يتعلق بانها
مكشوفه على الارض بنسبه الامريكان
تهديد بمعنى اخر
الولايات المتحده الان تستغل اي فرصه
للتاكيد على انها يعني تتبع اوروبا
تصلحيه نوعا ما ترجاها روسيا وبانها لا
تريد بالفعل ان تدخل في اي صدام عسكريه
مباشره ولكن هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى نحن
نرى ان استمرار الولايات المتحده في
تزويده اوكرانيا بكل ما همم يعني تطلب
منهم القياده الاوكرانيه هذا الامر ليس من
شانه الا ان يطيل امد الحرب وبالتالي الذي
يؤدي الى هذه النتائج التي تتمناها
الولايات المتحده
الان من قبل الولايات المتحده في هذا
التقرير الا يحرج الولايات المتحده امام
اوكرانيا بالمقابل
ليه اعتقد بانها يخرج او غير او لا تحرج
ولكن هنا النقطه لافته ايضا هي ان حتى
القائد العام للقوات الاوكرانيه
قيم مؤخرا وعده مرات تقييما عاليا
الاستراتيجيه البارزه الذي يملكها رئيس
هيئه الاركان الروسيه
غاليه القائد العام للقوات الاوكرانيه انه
تعلم منه من خبرته في التكتك
والاستراتيجيه وهذا يعني ان الجانب
الاوكراني ايضا مضطر ل- الاعتراف ربما
بالقدره الترتيكيه العاليه التي همم
يملكها القائد الروسيه
همم لاعود الى تقرير لانه ايضا يظهر
الاخطاء واسباب الاخفاقات الروسيه وشاهدنا
بعضها من خلال
دي حبات الموجوده وربما يمكن ان نضيف
عليها عوده الكهرباء والماء
للعاصمه كيف وبالتالي الا تعتقد انه ايضا
بالمقابل هناك ربما نوع من المصداقيه في
ما يتعلق بالاخفاقات وخاصه انهم يقولون
بانهم اخذوا المعلومات من جنودروس
الحال هناك اخطاء وهناك اخوات ومنها ربما
تكتيكيه وغيرها ولكن همم الجدل الذي يدور
حتى بداخل روسيا حول هذا الموضوع يحمل له
طبعا ايجابيا وليس طبعا انتقاديا حادا
وليس هناك من اصوات تطالب مثلا بالمزيد من
الاقساط واستبدال القاده العسكريين باخرين
نحن لا نعرف اي تعيين باريس غير تعيد واحد
وهو قائد عام للقوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
السيد
شكرا جزيلا لك
في الخامس ولاكن بعد قليل
مقتل لو 19 شخصا بانفجار صهريج وقود شمال
العاصمه الافغانيه كابول
[موسيقى]
ولا ترضى بشيء عادي لكن المراعي اجود
زبادي مع زبادي المراعي في الاكل صحيه
مع فيتامين سي وزنك وفيتامين دال يساعد
على تعزيز مناعتك يوم بعد يوم خلي سنترم
جزء من روتينك اليومي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جديد يلعبوا قطاع السياحه في الاقتصاد
السعودي باستداف توفير مليون وظيفه جديده
وتسجيل 100 مليون زياره سنويا في 2030
بحسب برؤيه المملكه اليوم وبعد تسجيل 92
مليون زياره للمملكه في 2021 والمساهمه
باثر من 5% من الاقتصاد السعودي فكيف يمكن
للسياحه ان تساهم بعشره في المياه وكيف
تصبح السعوديه وجهه عالميه السياحه
السعوديه ضمن الاسواق العربيه
يد الام ياما شاف الطول هالمشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بيدين الامهات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا المشاهدين
والمباراه المرتقبه بين فرنسا والارجنتين
والمزيد حول الاجواء ينضم الينا من الدوحه
العربيه اقل من ربع ساعه او اكثر من ربع
ساعه بشويه
خبرنا عن الاجواء
[موسيقى]
الاجواء كما تشاهدين هالمره ميسون الكثير
من يهرول وعلى رجال لدخول همم ليحضر
المباراه داخل هذا السادس
ولكن هناك شباب اتوا من فلسطين من بلده
سلفيت تحديدا وطبعا انت تعلمين ان الطريق
صعبه حتى يصل من فلسطين ومن ثم يقطعون
الجسر الى الاردن ومن ثم طائره الى قطر
فقط لتشييع المنتخب الارجنتيني متى وصلته
امبارح كيف همم كيف كانت الطريقه اول شيء
طلع سهله يعني من المطار كل شيء سريع بس
الغلبه يعني من الجسر للاردن لهون الحدود
تشجعوا المنتخب
الارجنتيني
صحبكم للارجنتين
كذا سنه وصل للنهايه وما قدر يحقق لك فان
شاء الله
ثلاث واحد ان شاء الله ارجنتين
كمل التشجيع المنتخب الارجنتيني شو بتعمل
صراخ بنحاول نشارك الجمهور الكلمات نعرفها
وحماس على كل حال ميسون قبل ذلك قبل
المباشر قال لي احدهم اتوقع انت قالولي
يجب ان نذهب مباشره الى استاجر حتى نكون
بتحديد الاجواء نحمل الجو
بالعربي البسيط تحميه الاجواء داخل الملعب
ومشاركه المشجعين الارجنتينيين الذين
وصلوا من ساعات مبكر الى الملعب
واستوقفتهم طبعا عندما شاهدت انهم كانوا
هيك متحمسين كثير فهذا جزء من من تشجيع
المنتخب الارجنتيني اترككم تروحوا لانه
بلاش تتاخروا على كل حال الحمد لله
شكرا
جزيلا لك
اذا المشاهدين حماس واثاره استبرت ما
يقارب الشهر استولت فيه الساحره المستديره
على اهتمام العالم اجمع نشطات خارجيه
ومتابعه لمباريات كره القدم والتشجيع
الناري كلها كانت تملا اوقات المشجعين
وبشكل شبه يومي اخر المباريات تنتظر عشاق
كره القدم اليوم مع النهائي الذي يتوجه
فيه منتخبات فرنسا والارجنتين لتعود بعدها
الحياه لايقاعها السابق فراغ عاطفي سيصيب
الجماهير هذا ما تتوقعه منظمه الصحه
العقليه الامريكيه ليعانوا من الكسل وايضا
من الحزن الحل الانسب لتجنب الحاله بحسب
الخبره ايجاد انشطه اجتماعيه خارجيه بديله
او التوجه لهوايه ما ولكن الاهم هو تجنب
مشاهده اعاده المباريات
قالت الحكومه البريطانيه انها بصدق 1200
جندي ليحل محل سائقي سيارات الاسعاف
وموظفي الحدود المطربين في ظل اضراب
العديد من نقابات القطاع العام عن العمل
من المقرر ان تدخل طواقم الاسعاف اضرابا
يوم الاربعاء لينضموا الى منتسبي قطاع
التمريض وموظفي السكك الحديد والجوازات
وعمال البريد الذين ينظمون جميعا سلسله من
الاضرابات في الاسابيع المقبله تشير
حسابات الحكومه الى ان الراي العام سوف
ينقلب على النقابات لان المواطنين في جميع
انحاء المملكه المتحده يواجهنا تاجيل
مواعيد المستشفيات والغاء القطارات وتاخير
السفر خلال موسم العطلات الشتويه لكن
استطلاعات الراي تظهره مستوى عال من الدعم
للعمال خاصه منتسبي قطاع التمريض
قتل 19 شخصا على الاقل اصيب 32 اخرون في
انفجار صهريج وقود في النفق يقع الى شمال
العاصفه الافغانيه كابول حسب ما قال مسؤول
محليه المتحدث باسم ولاده بروان قال ان
الناجين ما زالوا مو حاصرين تحت الانقاذ
وان عدد الضحايا مرشح للارتفاع ولم يتطح
بعد سبب الحادث الذي وقع في حوالي الساعه
الثامنه والنصف مساء السبت قال مسؤول صحي
انا من بين القتل خمسه نساء وطفلان
والباقي رجال يصيبوا بحروق شديده ولا يمكن
تعرف عليهم
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه صاروخين ما اثر
مخاوف الجارتين كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
واعتبرته الاخيره تهديدا لامن المنطقه
واملها القوميه ايضا
علاقه جديده من مسلسل الصواريخ الكوريه
الشماليه تثير رعب دول الجوار مجددا
صاروخان بالستيان اطلقتهما كوريا الشماليه
باتجاه ساحلها الشرقي حلقه لمسافه 500 كلم
تعتبرهما اليابان تهديدا لامنها ولامن
المنطقه والمجتمع الدولي
تهدد سلامه وامن اليابان والمنطقه
والمجتمع الدولي ويجب عدم التسامح معها
انها تنتهي قرارات في مجلس الامن وقدمت
اليابان واحتجاجا جديدا ضد كوريا الشماليه
من خلال سفارتنا في بكين وادانه افعلهم
بشده
بعد ثلاثه ايام من اختبار كوريا الشماليه
لمحرك عالي القوه يعمل بالوقود الصلب
والذي يمكنها من تصنيع سلاح استراتيجيا
جديد يفسره المحللون انه صاروخ بالستين
عابر للقارات عن التقنيه وهو النوع الذي
يمكنها من الوصول الى البر الرئيسي
للولايات المتحده بحسب الخبراء
تصعيد طردي بين التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه للولايات المتحده وكوريا
الجنوبيه وبين التجارب الصاروخيه والنوويه
التي تنفذها بيونديانغ بما تعتبره الاخيره
تهديدا لامنها وتتناما ترسانتها من
الصواريخ البالستيه لتزداد كثافه
التدريبات المشتركه من جهه اخرى الا ان
الخبراء يفسرون هذه الدائره المغلقه من
التصعيد بانك تتذرع بالمناورات العسكريه
لتوسيع ارسالتها واستخدامها ورقه الضغط
على الولايات المتحده
وحليفتيها كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان الى
عمر العربيه
اكد رئيس اركان الجيش السوداني محمد عثمان
الحسين ان القوات المسلحه تؤيد اي اتفاق
سياسي يخرج السودان من ازماته اشار في
بيان الى انحياز القوات المسلحه السودانيه
للشعب لتحقيق تطالعاتها نحو التغيير شدد
رئيس الاركان السوداني على ان خروج القوات
المسلحه من العمل السياسي امر محسوم وان
اصلاح القوات المسلحه سيستمر بلا مزادات
سياسيه وعلى ايدي ابنائها وقياداتها
مع الاحتفال باليوم العالمي في اللغه
العربيه تبرز ازمه الانتشار الكبير
للعاميه وايضا تراجع استخدام اللغه
العربيه الفصحى في عدد من المجالات متابعه
وجمل تراها في الشوارع وعلى التوك توك
والسيارات وحتى في رسائل الهاتف
المصريون يرون ان الافراط في العاميه يعد
من اهم اسباب لهذا التظاهري خصوصا لدى
الاجيال الجديد الجديده
[موسيقى]
باللغه العاميه مشكله باللغه العربيه
الاولى وتكات تكون المشكله الاساسيه في كل
حاجه ان اللغه العربيه
اندثرت والعاميه طغرت على كل شيء في
الميديا والاعلام مسموع مقروء حتى
المكتبات التي تعد ملازا للمتذوقين
لجماليات للغه العربيه الفصحى بدات تسخر
بكتب العاميه الكتاب الجداد لما بيكتبوا
بالعاميه بيوصل له الشباب لان الشباب
للاسف ما تعلموش اللغه العربيه زي زمان
حاولنا رصد اسباب هذا التطهر امام المدارس
التجريبيه والحكوميه اكد الطلاب واولياء
امورهم ان سوق العمل المستقبلي يفرض اجاده
للغات الاجنبيه كاولويه للتعيين ما فيش
صعوبه في العربي ولا الانجليزي بس انا في
مصر تعتمد على انجلش يعني اكثر من اي لغه
ثانيه كمان لغه العربي لغه البلاد اساسا
يعني
تنفعني يا اما اكبر يعني مثلا عايزه اشغل
او اسافر بره تنفعني يا مجدي
احدى المدارس الخاصه يبدو المشهد مختلفا
اهتمام بتعلم العربي باساليب شيقه وممتعه
والهدف هو جعلها ماده محببه وليست مجرد
ماده للنجاح فحسب احنا دايما في تدريس
اللغه العربيه بنتجه للطرق اللي هي بتحبب
الاولاد في اللغه العربيه زي مثلا اغاني
بسيطه مثلا لعب هزار الحاجات دي هي بتبقى
قريبه جدا من سن الصغير وهي بتحببهم في
التدريب في اللغه العربيه بشكل عام
رف للصراع اقدام اقدام اخرون يحاولون
تغيير هذا النمط التقليدي في تعلم العربيه
واستبداده باساليب جاذبه للطلاب ان نهج
نفسه يسعى لبعض لتطبيقه مع الاطفال ويظل
الرهان على امكانيه ظهور الجيل الجديد محب
وعاشق للغته العربيه في عالم تهيمن فيه
لغات الاجنبيه
رهان ليس سهلا فاللغه لم تعد لسانا كما
كانت في السابق لكنها تحولت الى اداه مهمه
في سوق العمل وهو ما سيحدد مصير لغه الضاد
في المستقبل احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
عيد الميلاد في اوكرانيا تكدر الحرب صفوه
الا ان رساله السلام تجلد في زينه الشجره
الموجوده في الساحه الرئيسيه في العاصمه
كيف حمامات السلام تزين الشجره ويعتليها
شعار ان باله الاوكرانيه طبعا بدلا عن
النجمه التقليديه عمده كيا بشار الى ان
الشجره ايضا سيتم تزيينها باعلام الدول
التي قدمت الدعم لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا كما بدانا ننهي الخامسه مع هذه
الصور التي تاتينا مباشره من الدوحه وايضا
يمكن قسم الشاشه لنشاهد صور اخرى من بيونس
ايرس قبيله انطلاق مباراه نهائي كاس
العالم بين الارجنتين وفرنسا ثلاث دقائق
تقريبا تفصلنا عن بدء هذه المباراه
شكرا لمتابعه مشاهدينا